[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans l'afrique
honnête le continent africain attise les
convoitises principalement pour ses
richesses en matières premières
énergétiques minérale et agricoles il
est au coeur d'une bataille
géostratégique entre les grandes
puissances de ce monde matière première
source de convoitise d'instabilité dans
sécurité et de conflits mais pas encore
une source de croissance réel et de
valeur ajoutée on va essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe et se
connecter avec notre invité le docteur
yves ekoué amaïzo économiste directeur
d'afro century city un think tank un
groupe de réflexion et d'action il est
l'auteur de l'afrique est elle incapable
de s'unir levé l'intangibilité des
frontières et opter pour un passeport
commun paru en 2002 aux éditions l
harmattan docteur yves ekoué amaïzo
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans afrique connect
bonjour c'est moi qui vous remercie le
livre collectif et que vous avez cités
on était nombreux et je souhaitais
rappeler la mémoire du professeur joseph
ki zerbo qui nous a fait l'honneur de
faire la préface
docteur yves ekoué amaïzo l'afrique
regorge de richesses mais ne
représentent que 3% du pib mondial en
2021 quel état des lieux vous faites
d'abord
et c'est normal vous savez c'est un
continent qui depuis des
décennies des millénaires je dirais
presque a été une source finalement
d'approvisionnement d'approvisionnement
de l'ensemble du monde que ça se fasse
de manière disant
acceptable ou de manière moins
acceptable je prends ça laisse pas les
exploitations et autres et donc du coup
il ya eu quand même plusieurs siècles
logo en a empêché les ressources
humaines le capital humain finalement de
penser à réorganiser la façon de
produire de la richesse d'abord pour le
continent et plus largement pour
l'ensemble du monde et donc il s'agit
vraiment d'une source vous parlez de
matières premières c'est vraiment mot
adéquat puisque il s'agit de venir
prendre à la source quelque chose le
problème de fond c'est que c'est la
façon dont on le prend
alors on évoque les matières premières
mais est-ce que vous pouvez préciser ce
dont on parle
absolument les matières premières vous
savez le mou qui courent souvent les le
mot malédiction je voudrais que régis a
tout de suite aussi vous savez si les
diamants le pétrole ou autres étaient 1
francfort berlin ou paris ou autour de
graaf la france et l'allemagne je ne
pense pas qu'on parlerait d'ailleurs de
malédiction mais plutôt de bénédiction
dont c'est une bénédiction pour
l'afrique d'avoir toutes ces matières
premières le fond du problème est que si
tout le monde vient chercher c'est qu'on
vient chercher bien la bénédiction et
non pas la malédiction non ça c'est pour
le côté disons promotion quand j'entends
ici et là qui est quand même
relativement fausses le fond du problème
c'est un problème de gouvernance vous
avez dans vos introduction insisté sur
les richesses déchets seront bien
chercher parfois piller il s'agit bien
de cela le vrai problème c'est que nous
sommes en train de faire des analyses un
peu binaire il ne s'agit pas seulement
du nord et du sud c'est qu'il ya des
gens au nord qui pis est déjà au sud qui
pillent aussi et quand ce deux groupes
se retrouvent vous avez un problème de
fond que nous allons essayer de
clarifier dans ce que j'appelle ici la
gouvernance plutôt la mal gouvernance et
qui au fond créé à l'autre problème
intéressant qui est la dépendance celui
qui n'a pas la matière première on
donnera quelques chiffres tout à l'heure
il a intérêt à réduire au maximum sa
dépendance et il a souvent les armes la
force pour le faire qu'elles soient
diplomatiques ou pas il lui faut des
alliés d'où le problème en afrique qui
sont ses alliés et ses alliés ne peut
pas être n'importe qui encore moins des
populations dont ça nous permet d'être
que ceux qui détiennent des pouvoirs ou
qui sont à la tête d'un état
qu'ils soient légitimes pourquoi
démocratiquement élu ou pas donc la
première à docteur yves ekoué à mézos
ces matières premières il faut quand
même préciser
ce dont il s'agit
d'accord alors les matières premières
c'est chicago il ya deux grandes
distinctions d'abord 6 et énergétiques
ou pas et donc au pétrole gaz et autres
et tous les autres c'est plutôt des
minerais c'est plutôt le volet agricole
c'est peut-être même des métaux précieux
etc ça m'a même d'ailleurs à penser
autrement la notion de matières
premières et la notion de transformation
souvent automatiquement on pense à
l'industrie l'industrialisation en
réalité il faut mettre tous ces mots un
peu de côté et aller vers un nouveau
concept qu'on appelle les chaînes de
valeur ajoutée
qu'est ce que c'est il s'agit de penser
la matière première des moments une sort
s'il s'agit de la terre de la terre et
qu'ils arrivent faux produits finis que
nos utilisant par exemple portable et
toutes ces étapes que vous avez jusqu'au
bout téléphones portables sont des
possibilités de création de richesses et
donc de création de valeur ajoutée et
chacun peut se spécialiser à chaque
niveau 1re 2e 3e xx
x énième transformation et bien c'est
aussi vous contrôler l'ensemble de la
chaîne c'est qu'ils les essayent de
faire des entreprises transnationales
aux multinationales vous comprenez que
votre pouvoir en dehors de l'argent que
vous avez est très important à tel point
que vous pouvez même imposer vos prix à
ceux qui produisent cette matière
première la et si vous avez en plus des
partenaires en afrique qui jouent le jeu
plutôt du côté de ceux qui sont les plus
forts vous comprenez que nous avons une
situation d' échange inégal et surtout
asymétrique et là vous commencez à
comprendre mieux le problème de cette
matière première qui finalement est une
source de richesse même source de
pouvoir et donc une source d'aliénation
voire de servitude tout à l'heure vous
vous faisiez allusion à la problématique
de savoir comment on s'y prend justement
pour transformer ces matières premières
on va partir du côté d'abidjan avec
cette question pour vous dr yves écho à
maison
j'aimerais demander aux spécialistes de
la culture du cacao pourquoi l'afrique
transmet un petit peu ces matières
premières
[Musique]
alors docteur iveco à mézos sur cette
question pourquoi finalement le
continent peine à transformer ses
richesses
alors d'abord soyons clé la
transformation du cacao en particulier
l'ensemble de tout ce qui est un des
cols n'est pas un problème technique il
ya des équipements il ya des industries
à des usines et du savoir faire dont le
problème n'est pas technique on peut
l'acheter on peut l'acquérir on peut
inventer le problème qui se pose c'est
pourquoi c'est la question qui est posée
dont il ya soit des gens qui empêche
d'accéder à ce savoir pour transformer
le cacao sont le fait d'accéder et
bloqué impossible
vous commandez mais on vous envoie pas
des équipements et j'en ai vu ou
carrément on ne permet pas que vous
puissiez en fait avoir la même
technologie qu'ailleurs et donc
permettre un rattrapage voit un
dépassement de manière générale c'est un
manque de prise de conscience collectif
des dirigeants africains le mot
industrialisation le mot industrie est
venu plusieurs fois comme élément
prioritaire thèmes prioritaires de
l'union africaine qui m'a d'ailleurs
amené à avec mes amis à faire se dire
que l'équipe est ce que l'article est
incapable de s'unir pour organiser des
structures dans le domaine des matières
premières pour peser d'abord sur les
prix pour peser pour acquérir de la
technologie du savoir faire et de faire
en sorte que ces usines soit en afrique
parce que derrière vous avez la création
d'emplois et vous avez des emplois
décents maintenant si certains dans ce
jeu sont plutôt des traites si certains
dans ce jeu préfère s'aligner sur les
plus forts si certains ne défendent par
leurs populations vous comprenez que le
jeu devient tellement inégal que ça
conduit en fait à des insurrections des
difficultés avec les populations et si
en plus le système financier derrière
qui permet finalement de faire l'effet
de levier pour les petites et moyennes
entreprises n'est pas là donc pouvaient
pas accéder au crédit vous comprenez
bien que transformer le cacao ans n'a
rien d'extraordinaire on peut le faire
en plus à une petite échelle et faire de
chocolat de extrêmement très haute
qualité maintenant j'ai finalement jugé
le wi fi nalement le piétinement de de
la transformation des matières premières
vous l'imputé à la gabégie cessa de
certains hommes d'état à la culture de
rente aussi un bien sûr disons que il
n'ya pas un seul responsable c'est tout
un ensemble de chaînes des gens qui vont
s'accaparer un pouvoir et la richesse
qu'ils valent on peut le prendre dans
les eaux dans les deux sens le problème
en économie quand ça parle tout d'un
côté ça veut dire qu'un autre côté et
les est essentiellement les populations
dont le problème est d'abord une
compréhension je pense d'abord des gens
qui dirigent est il un autre problème de
fond on n'a peut-être pas dit encore
c'est la confiance au secteur privé
africain parce que en réalité l'état et
interventionniste en arsenic et par
cette avance interventionniste vous
connaissez la démocratie partout en
afrique en particulier par définition
ils sont plutôt incompétent pour pouvoir
gérer les petites activités de proximité
la gabégie des hommes d'état cette
culture de rente
ont la soci vous allez nous dire à tort
ou à raison justement à ce système aussi
de la françafrique qui est considéré
comme un système de prédation des
richesses en afrique francophone alors
la françafrique tout le monde est au
courant maintenant il s'agit d'un club
l'ésotérique de pouvoir d'argent pour
ensemble trouver un système de rente
souvent à partir des matières premières
et par définition de nombreuses
distributions aux populations y avait
bien une distribution mais elle se fait
entre un club fermé et perd sur certains
dirigeants africains jouent le jeu d'où
tout le problème d'ailleurs on peut même
le veau en a parlé du cacao mais aller
en finance dans la zone franc qui est la
zone francophone on se pose la question
pourquoi aujourd'hui on doit payer quand
quelqu'un envoient de l'argent de paris
au togo en côte d'ivoire pourquoi alors
qu'on est dans la même zone vous savez
très bien que le franc cfa n'est pas une
monnaie c'est un chèque du trésor
français et donc qu'est ce qui se passe
nous devrons être au même niveau il ya
donc un péché d'inégalités entre
l'autriche devant de l'argent en france
est la france qui envoie l'argent dans
un pays francophone est derrière cela il
faut bien qu une autorité locale
autorise cela et si cette autorité
locale permet se permet d'avoir un
pourcentage x de la transaction vous
comprenez qu'il n'a aucun intérêt à
faciliter une transaction transparente
et donc gratuites dont je rajouterais le
mot que vous avez dit la non
transparence parce qu'ils ne rendent pas
des comptes population est derrière
quand même un problème de fond est ce
qu'ils sont là pour représenter des
populations en grande majorité qui n'ont
pas demandé autre chose que simplement
d'avoir finalement un salaire décent ou
un pouvoir d'achat décent pour
fonctionner et c'est là qu'on a un
problème de fond parce qu on a des gens
qui trahissent la cause de l'afrique et
pourtant siège dans toutes les
structures décisionnelles que j'appelle
le maillage décisionnel africains contre
les populations africaines
on va poursuivre docteur iveco à mézos
mais on va marquer une courte pause on
se retrouve dans un instant dans afrique
onac rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
retour dans un free connect nous
évoquons avec le docteur yves ekoué à
mézos économistes la lenteur de la
transformation des matières premières
sur le continent africain on évoquait
justement les réseaux il ya aussi dr
iveco à mézos les politiques
d'ajustement structurel au sortir des
indépendances mise en place par les
institutions internationales avec ce qui
a suivi on sait aussi c'est
l'endettement ça aussi c'est un frein
absolument mais écoutez moi je vais
d'abord vous corriger un peu la
politique d'ajustement structurel comme
vous dites un loup techniquement on
l'appelle les politiques d'ajustement
conjoncturel mai à répétition c'est pour
ça qu'on ne s'en sont jamais c'est un
système qui a été mis en place qu'en où
vous êtes trop temps des andes et est
donc mal gouvernance dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure et quand vous rentrez
dans le système s'est fait en sorte que
vous ne puissiez pas vous vraiment vous
en sortir le seul pays actuellement en
afrique le gala est le seul qui n'a pas
de dette et qui officiellement géant un
peu mieux et du coup ne tombe plus dans
ce piège et peut se refinancer sur le
marché international mais la plupart des
autres pays sont donc dans cette
dépendance là sachez aussi que derrière
on parle du fmi ue banque mondiale ou
autre mais ce soit des états qui finance
ses institutions au sort c est à qui son
conseil d'administration donc ce sont
ces états là qu'ils donnent leur
conditionnalité qui sont transmis par
une organisation internationale
et d'ailleurs ça ne se limite pas à ces
organisations en a d'autres en afrique
qui servent de relais alors à partir de
là et quand on a dit cela qu'est-ce qui
se passe ces organisations ont leurs
propres règles de conditionnalité
si vous ne voulez pas avoir un problème
un vécu et il faut pas aller chez eux
donc il faut en fait bien gérer pour le
parent voir l'endettement donc dire que
c'est simplement eux qui sont fautifs
non sont responsables certainement dont
il faut revenir à la responsabilité de
la bonne gouvernance au niveau interne
pourquoi on n'a pas transformé pourquoi
le cacao en côte d'ivoire ne dépasse pas
3 ou 4% aujourd'hui de transformation ce
n'est pas normal on avait pensé même
avec le président ouattara qui était un
des plus durables libéral que tout cela
allait charger très vite oui il ya eu
quelques français qui ont délocalisé en
fait leur production leurs capacités de
production en côte d'ivoire parce qu'en
fait les taxes sont trop est pourtant en
france voyez bien mais ce ne sont pas
les ivoiriens qui transforme pour
illustrer un peu vos propos pour
poursuivre sur le cacao en côte d'ivoire
on va à partir du côté d'abidjan
justement la côte d'ivoire un producteur
de cacao qui désormais transforme sur
son sol ça aussi c'est une réalité sept
matières premières en produits finis et
commercialisé c'est un reportage signé
les la fin à nous où
la côte d'ivoire produit 40% du cacao
mondial mais non transforme qu'un tiers
sur place d'où l'objectif du
gouvernement de transformer 50 % du
cacao ivoirien et d'ici 2025 ce qui
incite bien sûr les initiatives privées
fulbert koffi est le fondateur de
l'ivoirienne de chocolaterie il se
décrit comme un entrepreneur activistes
qui milite pour le développement
économique de son pays il est
inconcevable pour moi qu'au 21e c'est
khaled internet qu'on puisse continuer
de transporter nos matières premières
brutes lorsqu'on transforme ça crée du
travail où les jeunes sur place et la
consommation permet d'augmenter selon
agrandi la chaîne de valeur de ses
produits pour se lancer ce chocolatier
ivoirien a dû franchir de nombreux
obstacles dont celui du financement le
nerf de la guerre comme bon nombre
d'entrepreneurs africains la solution
une levée de fonds via les réseaux
sociaux avec à la clé 36 millions de
francs cfa récoltés soit un peu plus de
55000 euros l'appel va trouver un large
écho au delà des frontières de la côte
d'ivoire on a pensé ivoiriens au départ
mais tous les africains ont les mêmes
problèmes on a des bonnes qui garde
seulement l'argent des citoyens on n'a
pas des banques qui accompagne
réellement il faut qu'il y ait un fonds
de solidarité pour les dut six
réalisations de l'afrique parce que les
discours on en a trop entendu
rien ne prédestinait fulbert koffi à la
production de chocolat ce journaliste de
formation se lance dans l'aventuré en
2020 excédée de voir que la majeure
partie du chocolat bron du en côte
d'ivoire vient de l'étranger dans la
zone industrielle de yopougon qui abrite
cette fois un géant du secteur le pari
est le même mais sans doute à plus
grande échelle depuis 2015 le groupe
français c'est moi produit un chocolat
100% made in côte d'ivoire avec pour
objectif conquérir non seulement les
ivoiriens mais aussi le marché ouest
africain et ses 350 millions de
consommateurs potentiels
le but aux pronos c'est que en plus sa
voix une gamme de produits que soient
adaptés à toutes les bourses entre des
produits de luxe et des produits qu'un
enfant pourrait avoir acheté dans des
petites échoppes sur ce site de 10
hectares le groupe qui transforme chaque
année 70 mille tonnes de fèves de cacao
mise sur des infrastructures
ultramodernes et le respect des normes
internationales pour concurrencer les
chocolats venus d'ailleurs on est
capable aujourd'hui ici de vendre à
travers le monde directement de la côte
d'ivoie avec un abattoir c'est sûr les
mêmes normes de qualité de process cette
une est certifiée iso 22000 on a aussi
des sept fica bio on a un label privé
qui s'appelle
transparence cacao qui garantit que le
cacao consorts dc est un cacao durable
en associant le cacao à d'autres
produits locaux tels que le gingembre la
noix de cajou ou encore le piment fut
bercot fils 80 à son échelle densité ses
compatriotes à la consommation de
chocolat imaginez-vous de chaque
africain en somme
une tasse de chocolat chaud le matin ça
va changer j'ai dit bien ça va changer
l'économie de l'afrique en côte d'ivoire
la consommation de produits dérivés du
cacao est estimé à moins de 200 grammes
par habitant et par an à titre de
comparaison en france elle est de plus
de 7 kg est un pays comme la suisse en
consomment plus de 10 kg leur brin
représente 10 % du pib ivoirien et 40%
des recettes d'exportation du pays il
ferait vivre près de 5 millions de
personnes sur une population de 26
millions d'habitants mais à l'heure
actuelle plus de la moitié des
cacaoculteurs vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté
alors ce qui ressort aussi de ce
reportage hormis effectivement la
transformation du cacao sur le sol
ivoirien c'est une attente des
populations depuis très longtemps on
s'aperçoit quand même que les sociétés
françaises elles font beaucoup d'ombré
aux petits producteurs confiseurs locaux
bonfort le mot ombre sera pas le mot
exact il ya deux choses que je rappelle
tout assaut d'abord je souscris
complètement à ce que fait ces ivoiriens
chez eux ce n'est pas aux réseaux
sociaux de financer le pme/pmi
ivoirienne ou africaine ce n'est pas le
réseau social c'est un système bancaire
adapté d'accompagnement aux pme pmi
c'est un système fiscal qui n'est pas
confiscatoire de l'état qui ne va pas
favoriser d'abord les investissements
étrangers par rapport aux 1 et vivent
des nationaux c'est un paiement de la
dette nationale ses terres les dettes
que l'état doit à des petites et
moyennes entreprises dans les temps et
n'ont pas favorisé pays d'abord la dette
internationale que ce soit femi ou
d'autres cela étant dit vous revenez au
sujet de fond que fait la côte d'ivoire
le ghana voisin ou d'autres pour ces
petites et moyennes entreprises en terme
de ces trois points fiscalité le
financement et l'accompagnement parce
que il faut rajouter deux ans la
formation vous avez bien vu ce qu'on a
dit au début celle de valeur c'était là
la l'acquisition des technologies que ce
sont en moyenne ou élevée c'était là et
la diversification parce que en a parlé
là du chocolat mais attendez vous avez
les déchets les déchirant dans
l'alimentation du bétail vous avez la
première chaîne de transformation qui
est le beurre de cacao tirant dans le
cosmétique et qui utilisé quasiment
partout vous imaginez ce que peut faire
la côte d'ivoire le ghana rien que ces
deux là si un tout petit peu de
transformations se fait au niveau du
beurre de cacao pour faire le maquillage
des filles chinoises rien que des filles
chinoises je vous dis que ils passent
tous au dessus du seuil de pauvreté et
passe même dans ce que j'appelle la
classe moyenne uniquement cela donc il
ya tout un travail de la chaîne à faire
pour trouver le bon marché il ne faut
pas se focaliser uniquement pour notre
question oui il ya des opérateurs
français je ne pense pas que ce soit eux
qui le circuit en tant que tel ce sont
des privés donc chacun essayait de
trouver faire sa concurrence ils
viennent avec un peu plus d'avantagés
qui viennent de france et bien avec des
technologies etc mais aujourd'hui c'est
diversifié le ghana voisin je suis j'ai
causé tant l'ia des ennemis les gens là
bas qui ont des équipements qui viennent
de chine beaucoup moins cher qu il
fonctionne en train d'écraser ils ont un
avantage de pouvoir juste avoir dominé
le marché notamment du chocolat oui mais
c'est le rôle de la fille c'est le rôle
de la fiscalité quand vous commencez la
première phase de l'indh officialisation
vous devez quand même soutenir au début
j'ai toujours un peu de pertes mais vous
devez soutenir le maroc aujourd'hui ne
sera pas indépendant en sucre si le roi
du maroc le président n'avait pas fait
tous les faux de soutenir toute la
production dans le domaine du sud pour
que le succès un sucre marocain quel que
soit le coût des parts et avec le temps
d'y songer à abidjan on repart à abidjan
l'ex est question un docteur avec la
maison non monsieur moi j'aimerais
savoir comment se fait il que l'afrique
est le lieu même où naissent toutes les
richesses qu'on ne parle de richelle je
parle de bauxite et tout et tout et on
n'arrive pas à se développer nous sommes
sûrs et a surtout les pays ça c'est ma
première question est la deuxième
question concerne en particulier la codi
one son premier producteur de cacao et
nous ne produisons pas de chocolat
n'avons pas de deux structures en côte
d'ivoire donc
à quoi est dû cela quelle solution
pourrait vous nous donner
alors ce que dit cette jeune ivoirienne
c'est vrai il ya longtemps c'est une
question qui se pose est la
transformation du chocolat en côte
d'ivoire on l'a dit c'est vrai qu'à une
omerta quand même sur le pillage de la
filière cacao en côte d'ivoire on en
parle très peu est ce qu ont même tenté
de d'enquêté l'ont fait au péril de leur
vie pour quelle raison un docteur yves
ekoué mais ce sont bien des raisons
c'est que il faut des surtout regarder
la composition des
l'actionnariat des entreprises notamment
françaises en côte d'ivoire et vous soit
est étonné d'y voir beaucoup d'hommes
politiques donc des gens qui sont dans
des situations de rentiers et qui ne
voudrait pas perdre c'est de rentrer là
j'ai parlé de chêne valeur tout à
l'heure ne restons pas que dans le cacao
en tant que produit penser qu'il faut
peut-être chez le rat chaos se
transporte passe par le port en
logistique transport et partent ailleurs
donc celui qui contrôle une partie du
port ivoirien cette partie de cela s'il
augmente les prix ben vous avez un petit
problème d'exploitation ci fait des
différenciations entre les ivoiriens qui
fait de chocolat qui mal exploité qui va
payer plus cher que quelqu'un d'autre
qui est lui français et qui paie moins
cher vous voyez ce que j'essaie de vous
dire donc on a une famille c'est vous il
ya encore une main de la politique sans
cesse il ya aujourd'hui mais bien bien
bien sûr non seulement une mainmise mais
en fait il s'en de
déconcentration du pouvoir vers des
acteurs privés qui agissent pour le
public que ce soit le public national ou
que ce soit le public international est
dedans vous avez des multinationales qui
ont un besoin d'approvisionnement pour
un tas de choses pour le pays ne peut
pas se permettre de perdre cet
approvisionnement donc la question de la
dame et les très précises pourquoi mais
j'ai détenu au départ c'est young
l'afrique est une source
d'approvisionnement en quasiment en tout
on n'a pas le temps ici mais je ferai un
papier là dessus pour bien expliquer que
dans la plupart des domaines l'europe et
d'une dépendance extraordinaire vous
avez une solution quelle solution et
quels modèles justement de
transformation pour rattraper le retard
on parlait tout à l'heure des politiques
d'ajustement structurels ou
conjoncturels
il ya eu des politique d'émergence
aujourd'hui encore est ce qu'il faut
diversifier il faut diversifier
l'économie il faut toujours diversifié
les chaînes de ballons il faut apprendre
à maîtriser certaines valeurs il faut
faire des études pour calculer les coûts
qui sait qu'ils profitent vous pouvez
pas faire aujourd'hui par exemple un jus
de fruits à partir de mangue et que le
transport ou l'emballage nous coûte 80 à
90% de l'ensemble dont vous ne buvez pas
de jus d'orange buvez de l'emballage ce
n'est pas normal c'est souvent le cas en
afrique et qui c'est qui contrôlent
l'emballage qui c'est qui contrôle le
transport c'est souvent pas des
africains donc déjà le premier problème
il faut d'abord faire une étude et une
analyse il faut utiliser les experts et
la diaspora africaine ils vont rejoindre
en l'occurrence pour faire ce travail
parce que si ce ne sont pas des gens
indépendants typhon l'étude vous voyez
le biais par les études et vous savez
que beaucoup de nos gouvernements
africains choisissent des grands
cabinets qui ont d'autres intérêts et
d'autres objectifs deuxième élément
important il faut une prise de
conscience parce que si vous n'êtes pas
conscient que le fait de transformer le
beurre de cacao avec de le rendre en
chine pour les femmes chinoises qui se
maquille vous devenez riche dans moins
de cinq à sept ans il ya un problème de
fond il faut quelqu'un s'occupe aussi
d'expliquer qu'il ya d'autres marchés
que la france troisième élément le plus
important la démocratie elle-même il
faut qu'elle soit vraie il faut qu'il
soit sur la vérité des yeux et la vérité
des comptes publics et se doit être
indépendant c'est pourquoi je dis ça
parce que sinon on vous donne des
informations qui sont inexactes ou qui
sont biaisés au kiné résume carrément
pas sur justement le cacao au tout le
circuit et vous n'allez pas voir qu'ils
sont ceux qui profitent de ce que
j'appelle le ruissellement et selon ce
n'est pas les gens en dernier ressort
c'est à dire les producteurs et c'est
encore moins certains à l'intérieur qui
sont des locaux dont la question était
bien posée pourquoi les africains les
ivryens en l'occurrence ne profite pas
de cette richesse là c'est qu'il ya dans
un accaparement le ruissellement ce
faire mais est ce réellement est déviée
vers ce qu'ils ont le pouvoir et dans
certains pays c'est même beaucoup plus
grave parce que les militaires entrent
dans le jeu l'armée rentrer dans le jeu
pour éviter les coups d'état on les
associe directement indirectement au
capital soit dans le transport soit dans
la logistique parce que c'est souvent
eux qui s'est un peu comment dire
accompagner les transports routiers et
des camions pour le papier des problèmes
et à ce moment là hier des tables souci
et d'ailleurs ça va très loin parce que
ça touche au terrorisme les terroristes
ont compris cette histoire 6e il ils
accaparent c'est le sait bien qui
circulent merci beaucoup à vous dr yves
ekoué
les eaux je rappelle le titre de votre
ouvrage pour aller plus loin l'afrique
est elle incapable de s'unir levé
l'intangibilité des frontières et opter
pour un passeport commun paru en 2002
donc aux éditions l'harmattan merci
encore à vous merci aux équipes du mag
et techniques pour la préparation de
cette émission et merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis retrouvez après connecte
sur nos réseaux sociaux et notre site rt
france point tv à très bientôt dans
l'après connecte sur arte france